I don't think I'll ever forget in my
life mom I made it to Harvard I mean
interest like a Bollywood Hollywood kind
of wasn't it
I'm Trey I'm a freshman at Harvard the
AUSA 2022 and I'm from New Delhi India
I've been using Khan Academy for quite a
while
sixth grade probably
chemistry is a subject that if you're
not deal with the fundamentals or the
building blocks you will really struggle
a lot when you get to like the higher
concepts when I struggle with chemistry
it was more about not getting enough
attention on the basic fundamental
things or the class being just too fast
paced for me Khan Academy eliminated
that for me to a great extent because I
didn't have to feel bad about watching
like the same with you over and over
again I could watch it at a slower pace
I could do like millions of questions at
the same level at the fundamental level
and I was great actually because I was
learning at my own pace Khan Academy
teaching just eliminates any sort of
learning gap this access to education
it's the greatest gift which we can give
to our kids wherever they are in this
world if they have access to this kind
of education through technology through
digital means through platforms like
Khan Academy they can achieve anything
you know a child sitting in any corner
of the world if they have is access to
these resources anything is possible
you